merci de votre présence nous reprenons
nos travaux et nous accueillons ce soir
monsieur le garde des sceaux c'est le
ministre
pour une audition qui en réalité porte
sur deux sujets
principalement monsieur le ministre bien
sûr sur le projet de loi d'orientation
et de programmation que vous du
ministère de la Justice que vous avez
déposé ainsi que le projet de loi
organique les mêmes relatifs à
l'ouverture la modernisation et la
responsabilité du corps judiciaire
donc là ce soir pour
nous présenter ce projet et sans doute
répondre aux questions de nos deux
rapporteurs madame
canaillé et Madame Verrien
Agnès canaillé Dominique Verrien
devrait-je dire
et bien sûr des autres collègues qui
souhaiteront prendre la parole au cours
de ces débats et puis
vous rajoutez à notre ordre du jour une
petite question d'actualité la semaine
dernière la commission des lois à
auditionné le maire de
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins monsieur Morez
qui a exactement la place où vous êtes
ce soir à décrit ce qu'il a vécu dans le
cadre de son mandat de maire et des
violences dont il a été l'objet et voir
même les actes criminels dont il a fait
l'objet et l'occasion de cette audition
il a énoncé un certain nombre de choses
singulièrement nous paraît utile que
vous puissiez nous éclairer monsieur le
ministre sur non pas la position de tous
les représentants de l'État absolu mais
en tous les cas ceux du ministère qui
dépendent de vous et c'est un élément du
procureur de la République puisque il
nous a fait des déclarations que dont
vous avez connaissance terme de laquelle
il dit que il avait effectivement déposé
plainte qui avait pas eu de suite je
veux pas rentrer plus loin dans le
détail puisque c'est la description
qu'il a faite de la situation et vous
savez que dans cette commission nous
sommes tous attachés au principe du
contradictoire
qui nous permet d'appréhender l'ensemble
des situations naturellement voilà et ça
représente pour laquelle on vous
remercie de nous dire sur ce point ce
que vous pouvez nous dire et nous
éclairer sur ce qui s'est passé en tout
cas pour ce qui concerne la partie
judiciaire de la situation voilà
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
comment se présente notre audition nous
sommes donnés une heure et demie
d'horloge je crois
plus ou moins un quart d'heure on verra
sachant que par avance je vous préviens
que je suis obligé de quitter la séance
à 20h mais que Madame ditfolco assura la
présidence si les choses ne sont pas
terminées je vous prie de m'excuser par
avance j'ai le ministre vous avez la
parole
ce président de la commission des lois
mesdames les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
je vous propose ce président de vous
présenter les grands axes des textes que
votre Commission examinera la semaine
prochaine et d'évoquer ensuite plus en
détail la question
combien cruciale de l'exposition de nos
élus
et de la violence intolérable qu'ils ont
de plus en plus souvent à subir et vous
connaissez l'engagement de nos
politiques pénale en la matière
alors je suis particulièrement heureux
de revenir devant vous cet après-midi
après une première audition du 10
janvier où j'étais venu en longueur vous
présenter l'ensemble du plan d'action
issu des états généraux de la justice je
vous avais annoncé une autre
programmation ainsi que son volet
organique nous y voici et conformément à
l'engagement du président de la
République et de la première ministre
pour la justice le moment est venu pour
moi de présenter ces textes
justice évidemment c'est d'abord des
moyens
le gars on constate délabrement qui a
été dressé par le Comité des États
généraux que vous avez monsieur le
Président pour partie composée c'est
pour ça et c'est pour pourquoi l'article
premier de la loi d'orientation et de
programmation
du ministère de la Justice pour 2023
2027 vous propose d'entériner une hausse
de crédit qui tiendront près de 11
milliards d'euros en 2027
sur les cinq prochaines années cumulées
les crédits du ministère de la Justice
augmenteront de près de
7,5 milliards d'euros à titre de
comparaison ils augmentaient de 2
milliards seulement sous le quinquennat
du président Sarkozy et de deux virgule
un milliard sous celui du président
Hollande
le Parlement vote le budget ils l'on
contrôle aussi l'affectation alors
concrètement à quoi vont servir ces
crédits massifs supplémentaires c'est ce
que vient préciser le rapport annexé qui
vous est soumis
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs la
mère de toutes les batailles ce sont les
recrutements massifs et rapides de
magistrats de greffier d'attacher de
justice j'y reviendrai d'agent
pénitentiaire d'agent administratifs
bref de tous ceux qui font vivre le
ministère
et pour graver cela dans le marbre j'ai
souhaité inscrire dans la loi le
recrutement de 10000 personnels
supplémentaires en création nette de
poste d'ici 2027 la répartition sera
affinée prochainement mais d'ores et
déjà je vous confirme que nous
recruterons
1500 magistrats 1500 greffiers et là
aussi j'ai souhaité le graver dans le
marbre de la loi de programmation
deuxième priorité de ces crédits
supplémentaires la revalorisation de ce
qui servent notre justice au quotidien
on peut pas annoncer d'un côté le plus
grand plan d'embauche de l'histoire de
la justice et de l'autre ne rien faire
pour attirer nos compatriotes vers ces
missions qui sont des missions
passionnantes mais il faut le dire
également des missions très difficiles
et c'est pourquoi me semble-t-il l'État
doit leur manifester sa reconnaissance
c'est ce que prévoit cette loi de
programmation
qui entérine d'importantes
revalorisation et notamment une hausse
de 1000 euros mensuel pour les
magistrats qui sera effectifs dès
l'automne pour récompenser en
récompenser et encourager leur
engagement quotidien je vous rappeler
qu'ils n'ont pas été augmentés depuis
revalorisation des greffiers bien sûr
sont qui vous le savez la justice ne
peut pas fonctionner je veux évidemment
leur rendre hommage c'est revalorisation
se feront dans un calendrier dédié de
négociations à l'automne et puis passage
historique et j'insiste puisqu'il est
réclamé par les syndicats depuis 20 ans
des agents pénitentiaires de la
catégorie C vers la catégorie B et pour
les officiers de la catégorie B vers la
catégorie A il était grand temps de
reconnaître le rôle indispensable de la
troisième force de sécurité intérieure
de notre pays et je dois vous dire je
suis assez fier non seulement d'être
leur ministre mais d'avoir pu changer
concrètement leur place au sein de la
fonction publique
troisième priorité de ces nouveaux
crédits la transformation numérique du
ministère dont la rapporteur
massénatrice Verrien est une des
spécialistes
le ministère de la Justice a longtemps
été considéré à juste titre je l'avoue
sans détour comme un mauvais voit un
très mauvais élève en la matière il
suffit d'ailleurs d'écouter les
magistrats et les greffiers souvent ils
sont freinés par une informatique et un
réseau qui ne sont pas à la hauteur le
but est clair à l'instar de la
juridiction administrative il faut
instaurer le 0 papier d'ici 2027 et pour
atteindre cet objectif évidemment il
nous faut une méthode c'est pourquoi
nous allons doter toutes les
juridictions d'experts informatiques
dédiées pour agir au plus près du
terrain avec le savoir-faire requis
lorsque et pardon pour cette familiarité
la bécane plante
nous allons également accroître
massivement la capacité des réseaux du
ministère pour fluidifier les connexions
à terme l'un de nos objectifs est aussi
d'avoir un seul compte qui permettrait
d'accéder à toutes les applications
informatiques afin d'éviter les doublons
de saisine notamment des greffes qui
leur font perdre un temps extrêmement
précieux
nous accélérons la mise à jour
concertée avec le terrain des logiciels
en matière civile je pense par exemple à
Portalis et en matière pénale c'est dans
le cadre des moyens permis par cette loi
de programmation que ce déploie
actuellement la procédure pénale
numérique en lien étroit avec le
ministère de l'Intérieur nous avons
désigné d'ailleurs un chef de fil unique
qui vient la Chancellerie qui sera
chargée de piloter efficacement pour le
compte des deux ministères
ce chantier tellement attendu par les
forces de l'an les magistrats et les
greffiers
la transformation numérique de la
justice doit également se faire en
direction de ce qu'elle sert c'est à
dire bien sûr le justiciable je vous
avais annoncé en janvier dernier le
lancement d'une application smartphone
justice à portée de doigts avait jeu
osé regroupant des fonctionnalités
importantes ces choses faites elle a été
lancée le 27 avril dernier dans une
version qui permet déjà par exemple de
trouver le lieu de justice le plus
proche autour de vous
de savoir si oui ou non vous êtes
éligible à l'aide juridictionnelle ou
encore de simuler le montant d'une
pension alimentaire cette application
que vous pourrez télécharger dans
quelques instants c'est justice.fr
elle a déjà été chargée plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de fois
l'impératif évidemment mais interdit
lorsque je m'adresse à vous mais je le
redis et je le suggère télécharger
justice.fr ça va monter en puissance
avec à chaque fois de nouvelles
fonctionnalités au gré des mises à jour
régulières
quatrième point la dernière priorité
absolue concerne bien sûr le programme
immobilier du ministère il se décompose
en deux axes majeurs d'abord
l'immobilier judiciaire c'est-à-dire la
construction de tribunaux
l'arrivée de 1500 magistrats de 1500
greffiers et des nombreux attachés de
justice ont évidemment nécessité une
augmentation et une rénovation massive
du parc judiciaire la question ne sera
pas de savoir si la justice va recruter
massivement mais plutôt si la justice va
réussir à accueillir ces nouveaux
recrutements massifs c'est pour ça c'est
pour ça que on a une vision
et une stratégie globale qui prévoit
d'investir de manière massive dans les
tribunaux de demain afin d'agir sur tous
les leviers pour améliorer les
conditions de travail de ceux qui
servent la justice car on bout de chaîne
c'est bien le justiciable qui en
bénéficiera pleinement concrètement sur
le quinquennat ce ne sont pas moins de
40 opérations de restructuration et de
rénovation de tribunaux et de cours qui
seront engagés ensuite
nous sommes souvent dans des situations
où ceux qui sur les plateaux de télé
réclament le plus de fermeté sont les
premiers à refuser l'implantation d'une
prison près de chez eux avec toujours
d'excellents arguments bien sûr on est
même parfois confronté à des situations
où nous concertons étroitement avec un
élu qui nous donne son accord
avant finalement de le retirer après
officialisation
notre engagement il est clair et le cap
il est il est fixé nous construirons
15000 places supplémentaires d'ici 2027
il en va tout d'abord de la bonne
application de ma politique pénale qui
est je le crois sans ambiguïté fermeté
sans démagogie sans populisme et
Humanisme sans angélisme
il envoie ensuite des conditions de
détention qui sont parfois indignes et
nul besoin d'un énième rapport pour en
prendre conscience vous en avez tous
conscience bien sûr je fais le tour des
prisons depuis plus de 40 ans
en tant qu'avocat et puis ensuite en
tant que ministre je connais la
dégradation d'un certain nombre
d'établissements j'ai pas de baguette
magique voyez-vous je n'ai qu'une
volonté politique forte avec des leviers
d'action réalistes et des moyens inédits
et ça ouvre parfois mieux que les Yaka
faucons les conditions indignes de
détention sont évidemment une
préoccupation importante en particulier
dans notre grande démocratie j'ai
d'ailleurs soutenu avec force votre
proposition de loi monsieur le Président
qui a permis de créer un recours contre
ces conditions indignes mais en matière
pénitentiaire comme d'ailleurs en
matière pénale faut se méfier des
solutions miracles
car ce sont toujours en réalité des
solutions mirages la construction des
prisons et la solution la plus lente
mais la plus sûre surtout qu'en
parallèle des constructions nous
investissons massivement dans les
rénovations c'est près de 130 millions
d'euros par an deux fois plus que sous
le quinquennat du président Hollande et
pour reprendre les mots d'un éminent
Premier ministre
qui fut aussi sénateur la pente est
raide
mais la route est droite
ce président le rapport du Comité des
États généraux au-delà d'un constat
lucide sur des moyens à cela de riche
qu'il a tout aussi lucidement indiqué
qu'une hausse des moyens budgétaires ne
suffirait pas à remettre durablement sur
pied l'institution judiciaire
le président l'a dit en ces mots tout ne
se résume pas à la question des moyens
c'est pourquoi en complément et
j'insiste sur ce mot nous vous
présentons une série de mesures qui
viennent réformer en profondeur sans
pour autant déstabiliser l'institution
et là encore je ne crois pas à la mesure
gadget je crois à la gestion rigoureuse
mes ambitieuse et au Cap clair car oui
une des innovations de cette loi de
réforme de la justice c'est de mettre
face aux réformes les moyens nécessaires
pour les appliquer correctement et
rattraper une partie du retard accumulée
depuis trois décennies
cette coordination entre moyen nouveau
et réformes nouvelles pour suite un
objectif divisé par deux les délais
aussi viles comme open
une justice qu'il trouve beaucoup trop
lente c'est la première chose que nous
disent les Français et c'est à ça qu'en
priorité il convient de remédier je veux
pas être trop long pour laisser
évidemment
le temps des questions et des réponses
je voudrais me concentrer sur les
principales mesures que et je vous
laisserai bien sûr m'interroger sur si
vous le souhaitez sur sur tel ou tel
article
les axes de réforme proposaient sont
clairs ils sont issus de vagues de
concertation qui ont été conduites
l'année dernière
sur sur la base des rapports des des
États généraux le premier axe c'est
celui de l'amélioration de
l'organisation de la justice selon
pardon une approche pragmatique et
innovante j'ai évoqué le souhait d'aller
plus dans la déconcentration du
ministère de la Justice en laissant
davantage d'autonomie ou juridictions
dans leur administration afin de ne
faire intervenir l'administration
centrale que lorsqu'elle est à la fois
utile en termes de support ou nécessaire
en termes d'arbitrage le ministère de la
Justice
et l'un des rares à ne voir pas su voir
voulu prendre le virage de la
déconcentration il faut aller beaucoup
plus loin en faisant confiance au chef
de cours au chef de juridiction aux
acteurs de terrain tout ne doit plus
remonter à la centrale il nous faut
responsabiliser les acteurs de terrain
cette nouvelle étape de déconcentration
relève en grande partie du niveau
réglementaire mais j'ai souhaité
inscrire cette orientation claire dans
le rapport annexé oui une organisation
plus efficace de l'administration de la
justice c'est aussi des moyens mieux
employés pour une gestion au plus près
des professionnels et des justiciers
ce président madame la rapporteur
canaillé sur cette question qui vous
tient à cœur je vous annonce que je vous
ferai parvenir ainsi qu'aux membres de
votre commission les projets de décret
en la matière à l'été
la amélioration de l'organisation des
juridictions
passe aussi par des expérimentations
innovantes avec un objectif concret
améliorer concrètement le service rendu
aux justiciable c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous proposons
une expérimentation
du tribunal des activités économiques le
constat il est simple l'organisation
actuelle des juridictions commerciales
et plus particulièrement le partage des
compétences en première instance entre
les tribunaux de commerce et les
tribunaux judiciaires selon les secteurs
d'activité manque de lisibilité pour les
justiciables et les différents acteurs
nous proposons donc d'expérimenter
j'insiste sur ce point les tribunaux des
activités économiques il s'agit de
conférer à certains tribunaux de
commerce entre 9 et 12 pendant 4 ans une
compétence étendue pour connaître de
toutes les procédures amiable et
collectives engagées par les acteurs
économiques quel que soit leur statut et
leur domaine d'activité à l'exception
des avocats et des officiers
ministériels
dans le cadre de ce Tae une
expérimentation complémentaire vous est
également proposé puisqu'il s'agit
d'instaurer une contribution économique
comme cela se pratique dans divers pays
européens
cette contribution consiste
et constitue une ressource
supplémentaire pour le service public de
la justice un moyen de lutte contre les
recours abusifs ainsi qu'une incitation
à recourir à un mode amiable de
règlement des différents elle permettra
aussi de bénéficier de l'effet Marc car
souvent dans le monde économique ce qui
est gratuit et perçu comme de moins
bonne qualité cette contribution tient
notamment compte de la capacité
contributive du demandeur bien sûr et
évidemment du montant de la demande les
bénéficiaires de l'aide juridique des
entreprises en difficulté et l'État en
seront évidemment dispensés
une amélioration de l'organisation de
nos juridictions mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs de dossiers être opérés
dans les politiques pénales prioritaires
je pense bien sûr la question de la
lutte contre les violences intra
familiales
madame la rapporteur
vérien Jérôme hier au gouvernement un
rapport de grande qualité
corréligées avec la députée Émilie
Chandler qui préconise justement une
véritable adaptation de toutes les
juridictions à se contentieux de masse
avec la création de Paul spécialisés j'y
suis tout particulièrement favorable
cette nouvelle organisation sera
inscrite dans le Code de l'organisation
judiciaire par un décret qui vous sera
transmis et qui sera pris à l'été je
vous proposerai d'inscrire cette
orientation dans le rapport annexé
un dernier exemple assez parlant de
notre approche en matière d'organisation
consiste en la possibilité pour le chef
de juridiction de désigner tout
magistrat du siège pour exercer les
attributions de juge de la liberté et de
la détention en matière civile comme les
hospitalisations d'offices et
administratives notamment en matière de
contention des étrangers
contentieux des étrangers en effet
ce qui est aussi le litige de la
contention le lundi donc
le natif le lapsus n'est révélateur de
rien
mais la mauvaise foi la mauvaise foi ne
se présume jamais monsieur sénateur en
effet ça permettra aux juridictions de
renouer avec davantage de souplesse dans
leur organisation en autorisant en
réalité la participation d'un nom plus
important de magistrat du siège au
traitement des atteintes aux libertés en
dehors évidemment du champ pénal
deuxième axe et celui de la
modernisation des ressources humaines
magistrats et fonctionnaires de la
Chancellerie l'idée elle est toute
simple nous souhaitons employer tous les
leviers à notre disposition pour
s'assurer que non seulement le plan de
recrutement pour être réalisé mais
surtout qu'il correspondra aux besoins
du terrain cette modernisation implique
d'abord une adaptation de ces ressources
à la réalité d'aujourd'hui et notamment
celle de la diversification des
fonctions je pense par exemple au
travail formidable réalisé par les
contractuels dans
nos juridictions le recrutement
l'engagement des magistrats et des
greffiers ont permis de réduire les
stocks de près de 30% dans les
juridictions et c'est pourquoi en plus
des recrutements massifs de magistrats
et de greffiers la loi de programmation
vous propose non seulement de pérenniser
ces emplois mais de les
institutionnaliser avec la création de
la fonction d'attacher de justice ces
attachés de justice seront formés à
l'ENM et ils prêteront il viendront
compléter et constituer une véritable
équipe autour du magistrat j'y
reviendrai mais cette équipe que nous
appelons de nos vœux constituent la
vraie révolution à venir au sein de la
justice
je précise d'ailleurs que la loi de
programmation propose également de CDI
tous les contractuels recrutés dans le
cadre de la justice de proximité ces
renforts que d'aucun craignait comme
éphémère devient aujourd'hui durable et
pérenne avec ce texte
c'est dans cette même impulsion que nous
souhaitons donner à l'administration
pénitentiaire
il s'agit de la plus grande réforme de
l'ordonnance statutaire depuis plus de
20 ans
elle tourne autour de trois axes
l'ouverture d'abord du corps judiciaire
recruter 1500 magistrats va nécessiter
de faciliter l'accès à la magistrature
et pour ça nous proposons la création de
magistrats en service extraordinaire
mais également l'ouverture des
recrutements en simplifiant les
différentes voies d'accès notamment pour
les avocats et en professionnalisant le
recrutement par l'instauration d'un jury
professionnel le principe du maintien le
maintien pardon du principe du concours
républicain nous garantira évidemment
l'excellence du niveau de recrutement
mais l'objectif c'est aussi d'assouplir
les règles pour les magistrats titres
temporaires qui font un travail
absolument remarquable dont on a besoin
pour mettre en place la politique de
l'amiable et pour renforcer les cours
criminels départementales et enfin
il s'agit également de simplifier
certaines règles de gestion des
ressources humaines comme périnisation
des brigades de soutien de magistrats et
greffiers qui font leurs preuves
actuellement à Mayotte et en Guyane mis
en place des priorités d'affectation des
magistrats qui ont accepté de partir
dans des territoires peu attractifs
création d'un troisième grade pour
garder des magistrats d'expériences en
première instance afin notamment dans
améliorer la qualité
conformément à ce que le rapport Sauvé a
exprimé le deuxième axe de la réforme
statutaire repose évidemment sur la
modernisation et notamment celle du
dialogue social ou du mode de scrutin au
Conseil supérieur de la magistrature
enfin le dernier axe repose sur la
responsabilité du corps judiciaire avec
notamment
l'élargissement à la fois des conditions
de recevabilité des plaintes de
justiciables contre des magistrats
devant le CSM aujourd'hui je vous
rappelle que sur 2500 plaintes aucune ne
donne lieu à sanction infinie aucune
et des pouvoirs d'enquête du CSM pour
instruire ces plaintes via la
possibilité de saisir l'inspection
générale de la justice le troisième
chantier de réforme est celui de la
simplification d'un certain nombre de
procédures qu'elles soient civiles ou
pénales sont un facteur de complexité
pour les non professionnels et
d'éloignement entre le citoyen et notre
justice vous le savez en matière civile
je veux simplifier la procédure d'appel
en réformant le décret Majin dit et
surtout faire enfin advenir la
révolution de l'amiable qui se fait tant
attendre dans notre pays ces réformes
sont de niveau réglementaires mais je
vous annonce que comme d'ailleurs je m'y
étais précédemment engagé je vous ferai
parvenir cette semaine les projets de
décret relatifs à la mise en place de la
césure et de l'audience de règlement
amiable j'insiste mon plan d'action
est un tout cohérent budgétaire
législatif réglementaire et il est
important essentiel à mes yeux que le
Parlement puisse en avoir bien sûr une
vue d'ensemble en matière pénale je
souhaite que nous puissions lancer
ensemble le chantier si j'ose dire
titanesque de la simplification de la
procédure pénale
il s'agit dans un premier temps
de restructurer le code de le toiletter
dans le cadre d'un travail
extrêmement important qui à la suite de
diverses consultations et notamment du
président de votre commission sera bien
évidemment
les adverbes sont utiles à droit
constant
c'est d'ailleurs noir sur blanc écrit à
l'article 2 de la loi de programmation
l'objectif est de rendre plus lisible
plus clair le code de procédure pénale
pour les professionnels réécrire des
articles qui sont écrits par renvoi
successifs à d'autres articles
réorganiser l'ensemble des chapitres
regroupés certains textes épars pour
éviter des erreurs procédurales pour
garantir que cette réécriture se fera
bien à droite constant j'ai mis en place
un comité scientifique et je vous
proposerai la mise en place d'un groupe
de liaisons avec l'ensemble des groupes
parlementaires et des deux présidents
commissions des lois enfin je rappelle
que lorsqu'une codification est faite à
droit constant
elle est soumise
à de nombreux contrôles notamment de la
commission supérieure de codification
dont le président Richard
et membre ou encore le Conseil d'État
ces institutions imposent quoi elles
imposent au gouvernement de respecter la
lettre de l'habilitation mais aussi
l'esprit de l'habilitation octroyé par
le législateur enfin et j'en terminerai
par là concernant les textes de loi il
vous est proposé une série de mesures
concrètes immédiatement applicable je
pense par exemple à des mesures
améliorant l'efficacité de l'enquête
pénale
mais nous aurons le temps d'y revenir et
aux questions seront sans doute pour moi
l'occasion de répondre à un certain
nombre d'inquiétudes qui sont vous le
verrez sans fondement je pense également
à l'extension de la possibilité des
travaux d'intérêt général aux
entreprises du secteur de l'économie
sociale et solidaire
je pense enfin l'extension du champ des
infractions recevables pour une
indemnisation des victimes
je pense également aux mesures relatives
aux professions du droit avec la mise en
place de la dématérialisation des
déclarations de créances dans le cas des
procédures collectives la nouvelle
plateforme qui a été mise en place
permettra un suivi complet de la
procédure avec un coût extrêmement
réduit pour le justicien nous allons
également accompagner la nouvelle
profession de commissaire de justice
afin qu'elle puisse prendre en charge
sous le contrôle d'un juge le traitement
des saisies des rémunérations ce qui va
considérablement allégé le travail de
nos greffiers d'autres professions
réglementées du droit seront
accompagnées dans leur modernisation
réforme de la profession des avocats se
renoncés et la base légale permettant
aux greffier des tribunaux de commerce
de percevoir des honoraires libres
supprimer par erreur en 2016 sera enfin
rétabli j'ai pu entrer j'ai pas pu
entrer dans le détail de toutes les
mesures mais je suis sûr que vos
questions permettront d'éclaircir un
certain nombre de points que vous
souhaitez voir éclaircir j'en termine
par un point essentiel de cette audition
la question évidemment des violences
faites aux élus et de la réponse de la
justice
la démission d'un maire c'est évidemment
un échec
collectif
je veux à nouveau apporter mon soutien
le plus total à tous nos élus
qui font un travail remarquable
[Musique]
c'est le don de soi c'est l'intérêt
général et je m'adresse aussi bien sûr
au maire de Saint-Brevin
s'attaquer un maire c'est s'attaquer à
la République
mais je voudrais dire
ce que fait mon ministère depuis mon
arrivée
d'abord en matière législative je veux
citer
la loi du 24 août 2021
qui a créé un délit de révélation
d'information relative à la vie privée
ou professionnelle d'une personne
investie d'un mandat électif ensuite la
loi confiances que j'ai portée du 22
décembre interdit l'avertissement pénal
probatoire pour les déliques commis à
l'encontre des élus toujours dans le but
de renforcer l'accompagnement et la
protection des élus la loi du 24 janvier
2023 porté par la présidente Delattre
que je veux ici
saluer mais nous avons travaillé de
concert
a permis aux assemblées d'élus et aux
différentes associations d'élus de se
constitué partie civile pour soutenir
pleinement OpenAL une personne investie
d'un mandat électif public victime
d'agression et sa famille
je n'ai pas été en reste s'agissant des
instructions de politique pénales que
j'ai adressé au procureur non mais
circulaires du 7 septembre et du 15
décembre 2020 j'ai réaffirmé
l'importance qui s'attache à la mise en
œuvre d'une politique pénale empreinte
de volontarisme de fermeté de célébrités
et d'un suivi judiciaire renforcé des
procédures pénales concernant les élus
afin qu'ils soient soutenus dans leur
action quotidienne et qu'ils puissent la
poursuivre sereinement j'ai ainsi
demandé au parquet une réponse pénale
rapide systématique on privilégiant les
déferments pour les faits les plus
graves
j'ai demandé que l'on privilégie la
comparution immédiate et de même
un magistrat de chaque parquet a été
désigné pour être l'interlocuteur
privilégié des élus du ressort les
juristes assistants ont également été
recrutés en nombre pour être ces petites
mains de la justice de proximité très
d'union souvent entre le maire et le
procureur local et à l'occasion de ma
nouvelle circulaire de politique
générale du 20 septembre
2022 j'ai demandé avec force au parquet
de poursuivre le renforcement des
échanges avec les élus en premier lieu
avec les mers et les Présidents de
Conseils départementaux voilà les
chiffres d'après les remontées
d'informations depuis 2018 le taux de
poursuite mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
et de 95% en cas d'atteinte aux élus
lorsque l'infraction est caractérisée
qu'un auteur a été identifié 100% des
mises en cause poursuivables font
l'objet d'une réponse pénale notamment
92% sous la forme d'une poursuite de mon
tribunal correctionnel c'est 10 points
de plus
10 points de plus que pour les autres
victimes et à ce titre une peine de
prison a été prononcée dans 84
84% des condamnations
contre les auteurs qui ont visé un maire
et dans cette affaire particulière de
Saint-Brevin la justice locale de ce qui
m'a été remontée n'a pas été aux abonnés
accents aux abonnés absents je tiens à
vous en dire deux mots même si
naturellement l'enquête est toujours en
cours et qu'il m'est interdit de
commenter une enquête
qui est en cours mais dès réceptions
d'un courrier qui a été adressé par le
maire de Saint-Brévin à la procureur de
Nantes le 15 février
la procureur de Saint-Nazaire a informé
téléphoniquement le directeur de cabinet
du maire que cette affaire relevée de sa
compétence territoriale non pas de
Nantes mais Saint-Nazaire et sa collègue
de Nantes a envoyé dès le 21 février
2023 une lettre à Monsieur Moret
l'informant de la transmission de son
courrier au parquet de Saint-Nazaire
pour compétence selon la formule
consacrée à la suite de la transmission
du courrier par son homologue nantais la
procureur de la République de
Saint-Nazaire a adressé au maire un
courrier le 27 février 2023 faisant
savoir celui-ci sa décision d'ouvrir une
enquête confiée à la brigade de
recherche de Pornic enfin après
l'incendie criminel du 22 mars la
procureur de Saint-Nazaire a eu
personnellement le maire au téléphone et
à communiquer à ce dernier son numéro de
téléphone portable personnel ce dossier
est actuellement traité au pôle criminel
de Nantes avec toutes les capacités
d'investigation
n'ont-ils dispose et conformément à mes
instructions générales les parquets
locaux ont donc toujours été en contact
avec ce maire menacé et ils ont pris
très au sérieux c'est fait en ouvrant
immédiatement des enquêtes qui je
l'espère vont aboutir très prochainement
merci monsieur le ministre pour cette
intervention je vais maintenant donner
la parole à nos rapporteurs je sais pas
si vous êtes mis d'accord sur une prise
de parole madame canaillé le maniès
canailler et puis madame Verrien et
ensuite Monsieur Jean-Pierre Sueur
madame Cécile cucarman monsieur Guy
benaroche et Madame Maryse Carrère
merci
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre donc nous y voilà c'est la mise
en œuvre par la voix législative des
dispositions attendus et concertées dans
le cadre des états généraux de la
justice et nous aborderons là le 6e
texte confort correspondant à une
réforme de la justice depuis 2017 sauf
que cette fois-ci s'appelle pas
confiance mais il embrasse de manière
générale l'ensemble des mesures qui sont
attendus pour réformer la justice
redonner confiance dans cette
institution et combattre le mal-être qui
existe aujourd'hui au sein de
juridictions vu l'ampleur des sujets
contenus dans ces deux textes prend pas
embrasser tout les dispositifs mais je
voudrais vous poser quatre questions la
première concerne les recrutements qui
est à l'art qui sont prévus et inscrits
dans le texte à l'article 1er du projet
de loi d'orientation et de programmation
et notamment les recrutements des
magistrats des 1500 magistrats
j'aimerais savoir combien seront
recrutés par la voix professionnelle et
pensez-vous ne pensez-vous pas que
la suspension des quotas sur cette voie
jusqu'en 2028
est un peu large et que est-elle
véritablement
utile pour
obtenir l'objectif que vous visez et en
parallèle qu'en est-il aujourd'hui de
l'évaluation de la charge des magistrats
qui permet de mieux définir les besoins
réels des juridictions et comment seront
recrutés les 6400 emplois restants
puisque je retire les 600 emplois déjà
pourvu pour l'année 2023 deuxième sujet
c'est l'équipe autour du magistrat
c'est un axe effectivement fondamental
des moyens supplémentaires mais aussi
une réorganisation
j'aimerais savoir clairement comment
cela s'articuler avec les greffes qui ne
sont pas compris dans cette équipe
autour du magistrat et quels seront les
profils particuliers des attachés de
justice troisième question autre sujet
central celui de l'article 2 sur
l'habilitation permettant de réformer le
code de procédure pénale comment
entendez-vous simplifier à droit
constant le code de procédure pénale
montant parlé de clarté mais on entend
quand même de la part des acteurs de la
justice que une simplification est
attendue et ma dernière question
concerne cette fois-ci l'article 3 et
les diverses mesures inscrites dans le
dur concernant cette réforme du code de
procédure pénale et notamment celle
relative au témoin assisté pourquoi
avez-vous pas été jusqu'au bout des
préconisations du rapport sauvé des de
la justice de faire du témoin assisté la
voix du droit commun et celle de la mise
en examen
la voix secondaire je vous remercie
merci Madame
merci monsieur le Président alors tout
d'abord monsieur le ministre je tenais à
vous remercier premier point par rapport
à cette introduction que vous proposez
dans le rapport annexé des pôles
spécialisés que nous vous avons proposé
dans le rapport donc
nous ne pouvons que nous en satisfaire
évidemment puisque cela montre que plus
que d'être écouté nous avons été
entendus
pour autant je voudrais vous demander
puisque aujourd'hui ça ne figure pas
encore dans le rapport quel type
d'organisation vous avez envisagé pour
ces pôles et ensuite vous mettre aussi
en garde entre ce qu'on souhaite mettre
en place et puis la pratique et vous
soulignez puisque j'ai pu échanger
aujourd'hui avec la procureur de
Châlons-en-Champagne dont vous savez
qu'elle est très engagée sur ces sujets
et qui avait une chargée de mission qui
permettait justement de bien coordonner
les différents acteurs concernant les
violences intrafamiliales
chargé de mission qui est parti en
février et dont elle attend
l'autorisation de la remplacer
autorisation qu'elle n'a toujours pas eu
nous sommes fin mai c'est aussi
d'ailleurs du coup
le la raison pour laquelle nous vous
préconisions et c'est notre
recommandation 58 un vrai pilotage de
cette politique y compris au sein du
ministère de la Justice pour veiller à
ce que les préconisations soient
réellement déployées et que les
juridictions soient accompagnées dans ce
déploiement
première question deuxième question les
tribunaux des affaires économiques que
vous souhaitez
expérimenter avec un élargissement on
l'a dit du périmètre et surtout la mise
en oeuvre d'une contribution pour la
justice économique cette contribution
telle qu'elle est prévue dans le texte
et de maximum 5% du montant du litige
dans la limite de 100.000 euros
mais c'est mon temps peuvent être
absolument énormes parce que on peut
avoir une petite entreprise qui pour des
raisons de sinistre bâtimentaires par
exemple peuvent avoir un gros litige
imaginons un million d'euros de litiges
et voici notre artisan qui doit payer 50
000 euros rien que pour avoir le droit
d'ester en justice alors on lit bien
dans votre texte qu'il est prévu des
mesures en fonction du chiffre
d'affaires en fonction des capacités
financières du demandeur c'est par des
craies est-ce que là encore on pourrait
avoir des détails sur ce décret et sur
ce que les entreprises auraient
effectivement à payer et toujours
puisqu'on parle de ce que les
entreprises auraient à payer et donc du
combien ça coûte je passerai sur
l'article 17 des saisies rémunérations
que vous a été confiée au commissaire de
justice
soit c'est vrai que ça va probablement
libérer des greffiers pour autant tout
travail méritant salaire j'imagine bien
que c'est commissaire de justice seront
rémunérés pour ces actes
dans un cadre non concurrentiel donc je
pense que ce sera là encore des des
honoraires encadrés fixés est-ce que
vous en avez déjà est-ce que vous avez
déjà une idée du montant
et enfin ma dernière question sur le
juge des libertés et de la détention
pour la partie civile que vous voulez
vous voulez libérer pour la partie
civile en donnant à n'importe lequel des
juges civils présents dans la
juridiction la possibilité de faire le
juge des libertés et de la détention
est-ce que il ne serait pas possible
d'orienter plus pour tout ce qui est
hospitalisation vers le juge des
contentieux de la protection et par
ailleurs pour les étrangers est-ce que
ce n'est pas malgré tout une justice un
peu spécialisée qui est enfin même
beaucoup spécialisée qui est nécessaire
et est-ce que tout juge civil serait
apte à
à avoir ce rôle
merci
Jean-Pierre Sueur
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
garde des sceaux je vais vous poser deux
questions la première au sujet des
prisons je n'ai pas entendu et je n'ai
pas lu non plus dans le texte de votre
de vos projets de loi ni dans les
exposés des motifs il n'a pas été
question de régulation carcérale c'est à
dire que vous pensez ou vous
laissez penser que la seule réponse elle
est de l'ordre de la construction de
prison construction d'ailleurs assez
difficile mais un rapport récent j'ai vu
que vous aviez dit que vous n'aviez pas
besoin d'un nouveau rapport je crois
pour comprendre l'allusion et d'ailleurs
je ne suis pas sûr qu'elle soit tout à
fait opportune mais un rapport récent
montre que plus on a construit de prison
plus elles étaient surpeuplées et cela
est un phénomène historique si on ne
choisit pas d'aller dans le sens que
préconise les états généraux de la
justice
vers eux une régulation tout simplement
ce qui doit être assorti évidemment de
toutes les peines alternatives etc et
bien je crains malheureusement qu'on ne
réponde pas à la question et il me
semble que ce serait l'objet d'une
programmation que de prévoir cela donc
je voulais savoir si votre pensée sur la
régulation a évoluer je sais que je vous
ai déjà posé cette question à plusieurs
reprises mais peut-être avez-vous
considérer la chose de manière
différente maintenant ma deuxième
question
porte sur une décision récente qui ne
vous a bien sûr pas échappé de la Cour
de cassation au sujet de la compétence
universelle du juge français vous aviez
bien voulu faire un communiqué
avec monsieur Jean-Yves Le Drian alors
au ministre des Affaires étrangères pour
dire que si c'est-à-dire un peu étrange
comme formulation si la justice bougeait
évoluait vous en tireriez les
conséquences législatives d'habitude
c'est plutôt le gouvernement qui propose
des lois et des juges là vous avez dit
que si dans sa sagesse la justice
évoluée et bien vous en tireriez les
conséquences législatives moi je trouve
que ce serait très bien que vous le
fassiez alors ce n'est pas prévu dans
l'état actuel de du projet de vos
projets de loi mais envisagez-vous que
ces projets de loi servent de véhicules
pour cette décision relative à la
compétence universelle et donc à la fin
de la double infraction notamment qui
est très attendu ou alors avez-vous
l'idée d'un autre vecteur législatif et
dans ce cas lequel je vous remercie
madame Cécile ku Kerman
merci Monsieur garde des sous pour cette
programme cette présentation pardon
complète bien évidemment dans le temps
imparti je ne vous interrogerai pas sur
l'ensemble des sujets qui qui nous
interroge et qui peuvent nous poser
question peut-être juste deux trois
points le premier plus la question du
texte organique et celle des magistrats
puisque de fait vous vous remplacez ce
qui existe existait c'est à dire la
nation sur titre par un nouveau concours
il y a de fortes inquiétudes sur compris
le qualitatif qui ressortira de ce
concours notamment avec une formation
très réduite de 12 mois et vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure alors certes en
parlant des prisons en parlant des
prisons mais les solutions miracles
peuvent aussi devenir des solutions
mirages et est-ce que à un moment donné
il n'y aurait pas une tentation qui en
voulant répondre effectivement à la
priorité que vous avez rappelé qui est
celle vécue en tout cas par nos
concitoyens comme une justice beaucoup
trop lente ferait que finalement certes
on ajouterait très rapidement du
quantitatif pas forcément du qualitatif
et qu'il y aurait finalement dans 5-6
ans une véritable problématique quand
a l'indépendance contre quant à la
formation quand à l'efficacité de ces de
ces nouveaux magistrats et donc de fait
parce que au-delà de la question de la
lenteur de la justice c'est bel et bien
et je crois l'enjeu en tout cas qui nous
anime toutes et tous aussi de pouvoir
réconcilier
redonner de la confiance envers
l'institution qui parfois est fortement
décrié et notamment alimenter également
par un certain nombre de commentaires
que l'on peut lire par voie de presse ou
sur différents réseaux qui ne sont pas
justes en tout cas rajoutent de la
défiance de nos concitoyens à l'égard de
la justice sur le texte de programmation
deux questions qui touchent plus l'une
l'article 13 puisque vous souhaitez être
à travers cet article transfert au juge
non spécialisé des fonctions civiles du
du JLD
il nous semble qu'on est là dans une
notion de de gestion de crise
et qui finalement n'interroge pas sur là
encore une réalité qui est la perte de
sens aujourd'hui de la fonction du JLD
et parfois de la difficulté d'ailleurs à
satisfaire sur sur ces différents postes
et puis sur la réforme de la procédure
pénale
comment est-ce que vous justifiez
aujourd'hui l'extension des
perquisitions de nuit pour les climes
les crimes pardon flagrant de droit
commun est-ce que finalement le droit en
vigueur
pas amplement suffisant pour pouvoir
collecter les preuves et donc la
banalisation finalement d'une procédure
pénale d'exception qui risque de
contrevenir à l'équilibre entre
protection de l'ordre public
indispensable mais aussi protection de
la vie privée des justiciables tout
autant indispensable en démocratie je
vous remercie merci Monsieur Guy
benaroche oui merci monsieur le
Président quatre questions de précision
la première a été déjà posée par
Jean-Pierre Sueur donc je la reposerai
pas sur les mécanismes de régulation
carcérale la seconde
concerne la des judiciarisation de la
saisine des rémunérations ma question
était en fait par cette mesure on
supprime quand même la conciliation qui
existait entre les parties et le juge
dans le rapport annexe vous proposez en
fait de développer toutes les procédures
de conciliation donc je voulais savoir
en fait comment vous articuler ce qui
paraît être a priori une contradiction
la troisième porte sur le système
d'information de la jur professionnels
et sur la mise en place de de votre site
internet dont vous avez parlé ma
question est sera-t-il quand même
possible pour les justiciables qui ne
souhaitent pas ou qui ne peuvent pas
effectuer cette demande par la voie des
matérialisés de présenter cette demande
par voie papier et la quatrième question
ça concerne les structures de de tige
donc du secteur privé en fait vous
souvenez bien que il y a une
expérimentation qui était en cours
depuis la publication de décret qui date
du 26 décembre 2019 et que six mois
avant la fin de cette expérimentation le
gouvernement devait adresser au
Parlement un rapport procédant à
l'évaluation de cette expérimentation on
aime bien évaluer les expérimentations
or ce rapport à ma connaissance n'a pas
été publié et vous envisagez de
généraliser l'expérimentation aux
personnes morales relevant de l'ESS et
de l'étendre aux sociétés objectifs
environnementaux donc la question que je
vous pose d'où sera-t-il possible
d'avoir ce rapport avant l'étude de
votre projet de loi et avant le dépôt de
nos amendements
merci Monsieur benaroche et enfin Madame
Laurence harib merci monsieur le
président monsieur le garde des sceaux
merci pour cette présentation et c'est
précisions quelques questions
complémentaires qui ont été dont
certaines ont été abordés donc j'irai
assez vite
je voudrais m'associer à la remarques
concernant le carcéral un seul article
dans une noix de programmation sachant
les problèmes qui se posent et les
besoins de ce secteur on est j'aimerais
savoir pourquoi ça n'a justifié qu'un
seul article dans une loi de
programmation ou en fait on aurait pu
attendre beaucoup plus
concernant les violences
intra-familiales par rapport à la à la
remarque de Dominique verrienne je
voudrais savoir si si vous êtes prêt à
intégrer lors de la discussion un
certain nombre donc d'amendements de
manière à préciser
rôle spécialisé mais au-delà la question
de l'ordonnance de protection possible
dès 24 heures
est-ce que vous allez faire des
modifications ou est-ce que nous est-ce
que vous êtes ouvert à des amendements
dans ce domaine là troisième sujet la
formation des magistrats
alors c'est vrai que il y a un domaine
réglementaire qui est important mais en
tout cas dans les auditions que nous
avons pu suivre autant la
diversification des recrutements peut
être considérée comme intéressantes et
en effet peu garantir une certaine
qualité du recrutement donc c'est plutôt
quelque chose qui est intéressant mais
ce qui ce qui est plus ce qui interroge
plus c'est la durée de formation et
est-ce que vous êtes prêt à modifier ces
durées de formation en particulier pour
les recrutements directs ou finalement
les auditions qu'on a pu avoir montrent
que la durée de formation n'est pas
suffisante
[Musique]
quatrième question les l'évaluation à
360 degrés qui pose un certain nombre de
d'interrogations aussi parce qu'il y a
pas eu d'expérimentation et j'aimerais
que vous soyez un petit peu plus précis
sur la question de la composition de la
composition de la de la commission
d'évaluation et enfin dernier élément
sur les juristes assistants qui semblent
en effet un élément vous avez parlé de
révolution la véritable révolution
l'équipe autour du juge en effet ça
semble quelque chose qui est qui est
très novateur et en tout cas qui peut
apporter des solutions mais et les
auditions qu'on a eu le montre à
condition que c'est que ces assistants
ces juristes assistants soient vraiment
focalisé sur une fonction d'appui au
juge et de deviennent pas quelque part
les supplétifs
un petit peu tout azimut d'une d'une
institution qui manque de moyens est-ce
que vous êtes prêt là aussi à préciser
et à donner une définition de leur
mission je vous remercie merci
et Madame Maryse Carrère merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues je souhaiterais revenir
sur le dernier point que vous avez
abordé monsieur garder sceaux sur
l'affaire de Saint-Brevin et l'audition
de du maire que nous avons eu la semaine
dernière
dans le cadre aussi de la mission que
j'ai le plaisir de présider avec Mathieu
Darnaud comme rapporteur sur l'avenir de
la commune et du maire
merci pour les précisions que vous avez
apportées sur au sujet de cette audition
et des démarches qui ont été faites par
par la procureur je me souhaitais de
façon plus précise sur cette affaire là
savoir si vous aviez eu connaissance de
la demande de protection rapprochée
qu'avait fait le maire et de sa prise en
considération ou pas
ensuite sur deux façons plus générale
lorsque nous avons commencé cette cette
mission au gré de notre déplacements et
de nos auditions on nous a auditionné
des maires qui ont été victimes
d'agression
ou qui ont subi des menaces ce qui nous
font remonter toujours c'est les délais
d'instruction de leurs affaires qui sont
trop longs et les réponses pénales qui
sont pas toujours adaptées ou qui leur
semblent être toujours souvent peut-être
un petit peu faible voilà donc ce que je
souhaitais vous demander si aujourd'hui
la prise en considération des agressions
elle est identique sur tous les
territoires parce qu'on a pu aussi au
gré de notre de nos déplacements voire
une
initiative d'un procureur sur un
département qui nous a paru tout à fait
intéressantes un procureur très proche
des élus très attentifs à cette question
et qui a d'ailleurs consacré une boîte
mail spécifique cifique qui relève
lui-même tous les jours pour
pour les maires donc pour précisément
ces sujets de d'agression donc voilà
merci beaucoup merci Madame Carrère bien
écoutez monsieur le ministre je crois
que c'est à votre retour
parce que de très très nombreuses
questions
madame canaille d'abord vous m'aviez
annoncé quatre questions mais
avec des sous questions mais essayez de
me faire un plaisir un plaisir un
plaisir de vous de vous répondre alors
d'abord sur le côté
de 50% de recrutement pour les excès et
pour les externes si je pondus qu'en
2028 puisque on a besoin de souplesse
tout simplement
il y a des faux nous nous avons
expertisé qu'on parviendrait pas à
recruter 1500 magistrats décident 2027
ce qui est quand même le but
ça c'est un tout premier élément de de
réponse
sur témoin insisté pourquoi on en fait
pas la règle
l'idée au fond c'est que le témoin
assisté aujourd'hui avait parfois
moins de droits que le mise en examen
alors que je le dis il faut prendre
cette phrase avec
[Musique]
10000 guillemets
il y a moins de choses contre le témoin
assisté que contre la mise en examen
contre le mise en examen il y a des
indices graves concordants contre témoin
assisté on est on est au-dessus et
pourtant il dispose de moins de droits
donc l'idée c'était de renforcer en
réalité ses droits et de lui permettre
d'accéder à davantage de contradictoires
notamment peut-être peut-être dans
l'espérance
d'une d'un règlement plus rapide de sa
procédure
alors moi je veux bien qu'on appelle
maintenant parce qu'au fond on change un
peu les choses la règle devient le
témoignage assisté oui mais enfin si on
fait des témoins insistés des mises si
on fait des mises en examen des témoins
assistés je sais pas trop ce que ça
change on est davantage sur une
évolution cosmétique moi j'ai souhaité
mon expérience d'avocat mis à conduit
dans la réflexion les États généraux
évoquent renforcer les droits du témoin
assisté je pense que je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui est qui est utile
nouvelle voie de recrutement bon ce
qu'on veut évidemment pour simplifier
les lois de recrutement
le véritable changement porte sur les
les anciennes voies d'accès latérales
qui sont supprimés elles sont remplacées
par un concours professionnel unique bon
et contrairement à la situation actuelle
toutes les personnes recrutées par cette
voie se verront offrir une formation
probatoire deuxièmement
on voulait maintenir les équilibres
entre les modes de recrutement et et
troisièmement permettre tout de suite
tout de suite rapidement la mise en
place les recrutements l'arrivée dans
les juridictions d'ailleurs je fais
remarquer que quand on évoque la
rapidité de justice qui revient de façon
vous savez que on avait ouvert à nos
compatriotes
la possibilité d'intervenir dans le
cadre de ces états généraux ce en quoi
d'ailleurs je le dis c'est un exercice
démocratique réussi parce que on a
obtenu un million de contributions ce
qui revient de façon
permanente insistante c'est la lenteur
de la justice
il y a un lien entre évidemment
l'arrivée des moyens magistrats
supplémentaires vérifier supplémentaire
attaché de justice et la façon dont la
justice
va
assimiler d'abord ces personnels
supplémentaires et puis
être plus plus plus
rapide à l'évidence et vous verrez quand
vous prendrez connaissance du volet
réglementaire sur l'amiable que
moi j'espère que nous nous gagnerons
nous diminuerons le le temps de
procédure et nous le diviserons par deux
un seul chiffre là-dessus ce n'est pas
l'objet de mon audition là mais au
Pays-Bas par exemple on cultive
l'amiable à hauteur de
80%, nous on est aux alentours de 1%, il
y a deux fois plus de contentieux civile
qui réglant deux fois moins de temps
donc
ça vaut quand même le coup d'aller
mettre en place cet amiable
sur la répartition des dix mille emplois
pour chaque pour chaque corps de métier
en particulier les pénitentiaires on
souhaite pas graver dans la loi le
recrutement qui sera fait sur les quatre
en restants afin de conserver en réalité
un peu de flexibilité dans la location
de nos moyens et de répondre aux besoins
exprimés au plus proche du terrain voilà
ça n'est rien d'autre que cela ensuite
à peu près madame madame c'est notre
canaillé même la rapporteur avoir
répondu non non il reste
la place du greffier dans l'équipe
autour du magistan évidemment c'est une
place absolument essentielle ils sont
garants du respect de la procédure et le
rôle ne peut pas être confondu avec le
rôle d'attaché de justice mais ils vont
intégrer cette équipe cette équipe
elle a plusieurs avantages d'abord vous
avez vu que
par différents vecteurs les magistrats
se sont exprimés la tribune des 3000
n'est pas que la tribune des 3000
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont dit ils ont parlé
de la solitude du magistrat l'équipe
permet de régler cette question
premièrement deuxièmement on va plus
vite ce que naturellement si vous avez
un juriste assistant
un attaché de justice qui va vous
chercher la jurisprudence qui va
chercher la doctrine là aussi on va plus
vite on a déjà expertisé par le passé
que un assistant de justice aux côtés
d'un magistrat c'est deux fois moins de
temps pour rendre une décision c'est à
dire que en fait ça bénéficie évidemment
aux justiciable puis la troisième chose
c'est que nous avons l'un vivier vous
avez des jeunes
c'est le profil si on brosse le portrait
à grand trait c'est jeune Master 1
Master 2 ils arrivent dans les
juridictions ici intègre parfaitement la
prestation de serment c'est pas que pour
la prestation de serment c'est aussi
pour qu'il soit totalement intégré dans
la famille judiciaire et d'ailleurs je
vous rappelais que les contacts actuels
au début on nous avait regardé avec
beaucoup de circonspection au mieux
beaucoup de critiques au pire puis
finalement les chefs de juridiction nous
ont demandé de les pérenniser ce que
nous avons fait donc ils sont utiles
évidemment et personne ne le conteste
aujourd'hui mais la prestation de
serment c'est aussi pour mieux les
intégrer ils font partie de la grande
maison judiciaire et
j'ai été un peu long mais c'est aussi un
olivier pour qu'il devienne magistrats
donc voilà les trois avantages de cette
équipe je passe maintenant à Madame la
rapporteur
rien alors je rappelle un pôle vif dans
chaque juridiction
les preneurs je l'ai dit voilà un
coordinateur siège un corps donateur
pardon siège coordonnateur parquet
magistrat référent en fonction de la
taille de l'activité de juridiction
renfort d'attacher de justice nos
fameuses attachés de justice et CDI
formation des personnels habilitation
par les chefs de juridiction très
important et si c'est nécessaire des
audiences spécialisées
[Musique]
moi je pense que ça tombe au fond assez
bien mais parfois le hasard fait bien
les choses et d'ailleurs est-ce que ça
tient au hasard j'en sais rien pas de
hasard diluar il y a que des rencontres
mais il y a votre rapport et puis le
texte qui arrive et tout ça peut
parfaitement se marier même la
rapporteur
la contribution d'abord je veux rappeler
sur la contribution que on est sur de
l'expérimental
donc on verra
mais nous nous avions été voir sur les
grandes places commerciales puis Paris a
la vocation de de dire une très très
grande place du droit
c'est payant et beaucoup de
de
d'entrepreneurs de très gros
entrepreneurs
défis un peu de la justice qui est la
nôtre parce qu'elle est gratuite je l'ai
dit c'est vrai bon me demandez pas
pourquoi
c'est un curieux réflexe mais c'est
comme ça puis on s'est dit que ça
pourrait venir abonder le budget de
l'État puis ça permet aux garde des
sceaux d'aller quand il va discuter le
budget raconter à Bercy que la justice
ne fait pas que coûter et quel rapporte
je pense au CJ je pense aux amandes je
pense à ce que nous allons mettre en
place et rapporte beaucoup d'argent
d'ailleurs bon moi je ferme cette
parenthèse alors 5%
100.000 euros on est là sur quelque
chose d'expérimental
va être précisé par décret prix en
Conseil d'État on va tenir compte dans
notre barème du montant de la demande de
la nature de litige de la capacité
contributive évidemment du du demandeur
pas question du tout pour les petites
boîtes
de payer c'est pas du tout le sens de de
cette de cette
de cette disposition nouvelle
s'agissant des
commissaires de justice
alors
d'abord il y a un véritable intérêt vous
l'avez rappelé mais je vous en remercie
pour les greffiers parce que c'est
vraiment une tâche répétitive
[Musique]
bon
il faut qu'on allait je travaille de nos
greffiers nos magistrats d'une
évidence
on va là aussi faire en sorte que des
garanties soient prises il faut pas que
ça coûte plus cher que mais
les garanties vont être liées à la
désignation du commissaire de justice
répartiteur
toutes les garanties vont être prises
votre question précisément était de
savoir si vous auriez communication des
éléments économiques que nous pouvons
mettre en place moi je n'y vois mais
alors strictement aucun inconvénient je
pense que c'est intéressant évidemment
de ce que c'est devant scénarin que nous
allons d'abord examiner le texte donc
quand est-ce qu'on pourra avoir de ce
point de vue des précisions sur le coût
de l'intervention du commissaire de
justice très prochainement
ce sera transmis bien sûr dès que nous
l'aurons qu'une aucune envie madame
rapporteur de sceller les choses et de
ne pas vous voulez vous les transmettre
mais il est évident que dans notre
esprit il faut que ça ait un coût
raisonnable
monsieur le sénateur
sur le sénateur sur alors
il y a il y a des choses qu'il faut
qu'il faut préciser sur
la création de de prison vous vous me
dites mais plus on en construit plus on
les remplit bon
alors moi je vais vous dire je suis
assez dubitatif mais aujourd'hui on a
13000 détenus pour pardon pour 60 60 un
peu plus de 60000 places
donc il y a pas 50 solutions où on
libère
plus de 10000 détenus
ouais mais il faut en assumer la
responsabilité des détenus qui ont été
envoyées en prison par des magistrats
dans le cadre de leur liberté
juridictionnelle bon
je suis pas certain que ça fasse pas une
révolution dans ce pays
parce que un moment
on n'a pas 50 000 solutions où on
construit des prisons et si on construit
on va au bout du programme alors il y a
la moitié des établissements
pénitentiaires qui seront sortis de
terre et opérationnelles l'année
prochaine j'inaugure 10 établissements
pénitenciers en cours d'ici la fin de
l'année 2024 on aura la moitié mais où
on construit plus de place de prison et
puis alors il y a plus de questions de
surpopulation carcérale où on prend la
responsabilité faites-moi cette
proposition de libérer 12000 détenus
dans ce pays parce que je rappelle que
quand Nicole Belloubet et elle a eu
raison de le faire à libérer des détenus
parce que il était dangereux dans la
promiscuité carcérale on était en pleine
pandémie vous avez vu les polémiques on
en parle encore aujourd'hui donc il y a
aussi ah non mais pardon il y a il y a
aussi ces équilibres si vous voulez
parce que l'extrême droite va s'emparer
de ça pour vous dire les choses de façon
cash
mais oui mais mais monsieur monsieur le
sénateur vous avez exprimé votre idée
là-dessus qui me soit permis d'exprimer
la mienne maintenant résumé cette
question de la surpopulation carcérale à
la construction d'établissements
pénitentiaire ça n'est pas vrai parce
que dans le texte d'ailleurs que je
soumets à votre appréciation on essaie
d'obtenir davantage de place de travail
d'intérêt général et puis deuxièmement
depuis le 1er janvier de cette année on
a mis en place la libération sous
contrainte et attendons de secondes de
voir ce que cela donne c'est un outil
qui est tout nouveau c'est une décision
qui je le rappelle est prise par un
magistrat
et lorsque l'on peut naturellement
écourter un reliquat de peine qui est
court mais avec des garanties qui sont
les garanties d'une insertion pour
éviter en réalité monsieur sénateur les
sorties sèches dont on sait qu'elles
sont génératrices de récidive le calcul
il faut le voir à très long terme parce
que certains peuvent dire ah oui mais on
va pas jusqu'au bout de la peine non
mais on va pas jusqu'au bout de la peine
avec des garanties des garanties
soumises à un magistrat et ne pas aller
vers la sortie sèche ce que le ce que
malheureusement on a déploré et nous
savons que le type-ci sort qui sort de
sa peine il la purgé mais il a pas de
boulot il a pas de logement on a très
bien compris statistiquement où ça va
non on peut pas dire que les tiges
la LSC se soit rien du tout ce sont des
façons aussi d'aller vers une régulation
j'ajoute aussi
il y a le contrat d'emploi pénitentiaire
qui est susceptible me semble-t-il quand
on remette enfin de peine en liberté des
détenus et qu'ils ont une formation ou
un travail ben moi je pense que c'est
payant et je pense que c'est payant et
que ça évite évidemment la récidive
voilà donc on peut pas dire il y a que
la construction des prisons maintenant
sur la jurisprudence vous m'avez
interrogé sur la jurisprudence moi je me
félicite je le dis de l'arrêt qui a été
rendu le 12 mai
par l'Assemblée plénière de l'accord de
cassation il vient clarifier
l'appréciation de la condition de double
incrémentation vous le savez dont
l'interprétation avait été durci par
l'arrêt Chaban il devrait permettre en
particulier aux procédures en cours
concernant les crimes qui ont été commis
en Syrie de prospérer bon j'ai pris
également note de la proposition de loi
déposée par le député gouvier chat qui
vise notamment à clarifier cette fois
dans la loi le critère de la double
incrémentation
je regarde tout ça avec beaucoup
d'intérêt je vous ai fait part de ma
position sur cet arrêt et nous allons
évidemment reparler
on peut l'intégrer dans la présente dans
les présentes
je suis pas convaincu qu'on ne sorte pas
des problèmes de recevabilité majeur oh
vous savez on est habitué
45 la parole est à Monsieur le Ministre
s'il vous plaît merci
excusez-moi mais cet arrêt tous ceux qui
comme vous sont préoccupés par la
compétence universelle des juridictions
françaises je pense qu'il a été lu et je
pense qu'il y aura des initiatives
parlementaires j'en ai déjà évoqué une
je pense que les choses sont
susceptibles sont susceptibles de
prospecter par le Sénat il y a 10 ans
oui mais je sais mais d'accord moi
j'étais pas là il y a 10 ans vous pouvez
me oui je sais c'est peut-être davantage
votre responsabilité que la mienne parce
que le sénateur
c'est peut-être davantage votre
responsabilité que la mienne et Madame
kuker madame la sénatrice bon
perquisition de nuit alors pourquoi
pourquoi perquisition de nuit bon
alors d'abord
c'est pas pour toutes les infractions
non mais je veux quand même le préciser
je vais vous dire la réalité c'est que
aujourd'hui si on suspecte quelqu'un
d'avoir commis un crime etc
il y a deux policiers ou deux gendarmes
qui vont surveiller toute la nuit devant
la porte alors moi je veux bien qu'on me
dise que le domicile est un lieu
protecteur sans aucun doute mais là on
est sur une protection qui n'est plus
que symbolique parce que si le titulaire
du domicile
veut sortir il aura pas franchi la porte
qui sera interpellé par ailleurs ce que
disent les policiers c'est vrai que je
les ai rencontrés j'ai rencontré tout le
monde d'ailleurs force de sécurité
intérieure avocat greffier magistrats
naturellement tous ceux qui participent
à l'oeuvre de justice policiers m'ont
dit mais
il y a aussi le risque d'un nettoyage
des lieux
et oui et si on se retrouve dans une
situation on a plus l'ombre de l'once
d'un indice parce que tout a été bien
nettoyé et encore un troisième risque
celui-là on peut pas l'écarter s'il y a
une victime que les policiers arrivent
on est à 23 heures
dans le régime actuel c'est compliqué de
perquisitionner c'est même illégal mais
s'il y a une autre victime encore en vie
voilà les raisons elles sont purement
pratiques c'est moi je
rappelle et je rappelle attendez j'ai
pas fini pour vous rassurer totalement
parce que ces questions de liberté sont
évidemment importantes elles ne
m'échappent pas moi vous savez
comme vous très attaché
aux libertés individuelles mais madame
la sénatrice il y a un Gilles D qui
ordonne cela
il y a un juge
garant de la liberté individuelle de par
notre texte suprême qui ordonne ou qui
n'ordonne pas donc voilà c'est soumis un
certain nombre de règles et de garantie
le JLD il intervient
vous me
posiez encore d'autres questions sur
sur
perquisition de nuit m'avait dit
sur le JLD ah oui bah voilà la
transition est toute trouvée bon alors
je veux que vous entendiez comment
comment on les on les met en place au
fond
ces états généraux ou ces textes
à partir du moment où on a fait deux
grandes vagues de concertation mais oui
mais écoutez-moi de seconde que je
défends mon texte moi avec ardeur parce
que il y a des jlds qui nous ont dit
nous on a trop de
contentieux aujourd'hui bon il y a le
contentieux qu'on tire du code de
procédure pénal d'accord et puis il y a
le contentieux qui a été ajouté
le Conseil constitutionnel a ajouté un
certain nombre de tâches etc etc bon
et donc certains JLD disent
nous on souhaite tout conserver d'autres
disent nous on en a trop et nous on
s'est dit ce que je rappelle quand même
et au tout début de mon discours que on
veut faire confiance aux acteurs de
terrain donc moi je dis mais pourquoi le
chef de juridiction
ne verrai pas avec son ou cjld ce qu'il
souhaite et pourquoi pas avec un autre
magistrat alors sur la question de mais
c'est trop compliqué pour un autre
magistrat moi je le crois pas du tout
parce que aujourd'hui déjà il y a du
contentieux des étrangers qui est traité
de cette façon et puis il y a toujours
la possibilité d'envisager la petite
formation la petite modification la
formation des magistrats le nm c'est
aussi à ça que ça sert c'est à former
les magistrats aussi au regard des
évolutions qui peuvent intervenir moi je
n'ai aucun doute là-dessus et puis
madame la sénatrice est-ce que vous
pouvez imaginer une seconde échelle de
juridiction qui va confier ce
contentieux là avec l'importance qu'il
revêt un magistrat qui lui dira un
moment c'est pas quelque chose que je
connais moi à part c'est pas du tout mon
contentieux mais pas du tout le chef de
juridiction il va aller chercher le
meilleur magistrat celui qui l'estime
être le meilleur pour traiter ce
contentieux voilà faire confiance aux
acteurs de terrain c'est ça aussi et
puis ça permet de de comment d'alléger
la charge de certains JLD ceux qui ne le
souhaiteront pas conserveront
l'intégralité du contentieux
monsieur le sénateur Bénin roche bien
sûr qu'on pourra toujours demander l'agi
par papier
c'est sûr j'ai dit tout à l'heure
l'appli que je vous ai suggéré de
télécharger bon
envisage aussi le bénéfice de la J ou
pas bon
entre parenthèses sur la proximité que
j'appelle de mes vœux
vous savez quand vous êtes j'ai pensé à
ça quand on l'a mis en place
vous êtes d'une femme vous êtes marié
vous souhaitez divorcer mais vous le
ferez pas tout de suite parce que vous
savez même pas comment vous allez
nourrir les enfants
regardez cette appli comme elle est
utile ça c'est de la justice de
proximité
ça c'est quelque chose qui parle à nos
compatriotes bon après il y a le
bénéfice de l'agi il y a 8000 fiches
thématiques ça va par exemple comment on
change de nom
puis il y a d'autres d'autres
explications mais vous allez me dire
puis vous aurez raison et tout le monde
n'a pas de portable bon
mais bien sûr que le papier il reste et
bien sûr qu'il y a les points justice
pour aller aussi chercher ses
renseignements pour les plus défavoriser
nos compatriés on en a plus de 2000
aujourd'hui donc ce n'est pas quelque
chose qui a été comment dirais-je
négligé l'accès de nos de nos
compatriotes les plus défavorisés à la
justice
j'indique j'y reviens parce que je vais
vous convaincre de ça mais on va vous
communiquer très très rapidement les
textes réglementaires que la justice de
proximité elle permet
la justice amiable pardon elle permet à
des justiciers de rencontrer leurs juges
de façon obligatoire
aujourd'hui vous avez des contentieux
qui touchent à l'intime plus profond des
êtres
et qui sont traités par mesure des
magistrats qui font leur travail qui
essaient de le faire le mieux possible
mais le justiciable il se dit mais j'ai
jamais rencontré mon juge
je l'ai pas vu et comment vous voulez
aimer la justice si elle n'est pas
incarnée à vos yeux voilà je ferme cette
petite cette petite parenthèse sur le
rapport d'évaluation sur les sociétés il
a été transmis en septembre et on vous
le fera évidemment parvenir je vous l'ai
déjà dit quand vous êtes venu me voir la
Chancellerie mais vous vous m'avez pas
cru vous l'avez oublié bon il arrive il
arrive il arrive bien ensuite madame la
sénatrice arrivez-vous vous inquiétude
sur l'évaluation des chefs de cours bon
on va on va construire je veux
construire avec le nouveau Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature
le contenu
évidemment en garantissant
et en préservant l'indépendance des
magistrats ça va de soi on exclut de ça
l'activité juridictionnelle dans lequel
le garde des sceaux n'a dans notre belle
démocratie rien à voir et c'est très
bien comme ça
mais
il y a comment dirais
il y a une large concertation qui sera
qui sera effectuée on avait déjà à titre
expérimental envisagé l'évaluation des
chefs de cours qui ne l'était pas et
cette discussion je l'ai eu avec le CSM
et on l'a fait ensemble bon donc il y a
aucune raison parce que en même temps
voyez-vous que on souhaite déconcentrer
les chefs de les chefs de cours vont
avoir des tâches supplémentaires si
j'ose dire
différente en tous les cas mais c'est le
prix de la déconcentration il faut aussi
qu'on puisse les évaluer là-dessus
certes vous voulez avoir davantage de de
prérogatifs sur le terrain prérogatif
budgétaire etc mais il faut aussi que
vous rendiez compte d'une certaine façon
de votre capacité à mener à bien ces
tâches qui ne sont plus les tâches qui
étaient celles d'autrefois c'est le prix
de la déconcentration aussi d'une
certaine façon il y aura d'ailleurs des
formations à l'ENM managériales par
exemple pour pour bien sûr bien
évidemment
alors l'article pour terminer peut-être
je ne sais pas mais l'article de la
recodidification allez savoir pourquoi
je je choisis ça à la fin
bon je les redis
on simplifie on ne touche en rien aux
équilibres
vous avez un certain nombre de textes
qui intrinsèquement renvoie à quatre
autres textes c'est à dire qu'il faut
regarder 5 pour avoir la solution c'est
une espèce de Cluedo
vous lisez le premier puis là vous allez
voir le second et puis vous allez encore
en voir un autre et encore un autre et
encore un autre
c'est devenu illisible c'est une réalité
n'y a-t-il pas possibilité de réécrire
tout cela en donnant exactement les
mêmes solutions
mais sans avoir quatre références à
quatre textes différents
c'est des choses trappes qui génèrent
des nullités qui génèrent des
difficultés qui génèrent de
l'incompréhension toutes les forces de
sécurité intérieure appellent à une
simplification du code de procédure
pénale bon j'en ai deux en ce moment sur
mon bureau j'en ai un 59 il est comme ça
j'en ai un 2023 il est comme ça
naturellement on va pas arriver à
l'épaisseur de celui de 59 ça n'aurait
strictement aucun sens mais oui
simplifier donner un bel outil réordonné
et on touche pas au fond et vous avez
toutes les garanties mais
tout bon d'abord la méditation
donc vous regardez ce qu'on vous propose
et je sais que les sénateurs ils savent
regarder ce qu'on leur propose puis ils
savent dire non quand c'est non bien
très bien un comité scientifique très
bien un suivi par le montant et vous
pourrez à tout moment dire au comité
scientifique là pas d'accord bon et puis
on arrive à la fin
habilitation c'est aussi un contrôle et
puis ensuite
l'excellence sénateur Richard veillez
sur tout ça et puis le Conseil d'État
mais franchement je vais vous dire autre
chose si on le fait pas maintenant cette
simplification on l'aura pas fait dans
20 ans voilà parce que c'est un boulot
titanesque est-ce que vous me voyez
arriver aujourd'hui 21 avec je sais pas
moi
280 articles pour simplifier que de
procédures pénal c'est un joueur
c'est un jouable disons-nous les choses
or cet outil là
simplifié mais pas modifié
il est attendu par tout le monde
par tout le monde j'ajoute d'ailleurs
que ça n'est quand même pas rien pardon
mais le Conseil d'État dans son avis
éthique pas là-dessus
vous l'avez lu la vie donc c'est quand
même une très belle garantie bon que que
le garde des sceaux s'échine vous dire
que nous serons dans le droit constant
j'entends que vous puissiez exprimer
votre circonspection voilà mais le
Conseil d'État le dit aussi la réalité
c'est que on a un outil qui est devenu
illisible faut le rendre lisible sans
bouger les choses et vous serez au fond
ce qui contrôleraient ce travail
accompli et voyez-vous
c'est tellement compliqué que le temps
dont veulent disposer d'en veut disposer
le comité scientifique c'est de l'ordre
de 18 mois 2 ans c'est dire la
complexité de la tâche moi je suis
désolé mais je peux pas présenter un
texte que l'on aurait élaboré en 18 mois
2 ans et venir ici comme je vous l'ai
dit avec 280 articles c'est c'est pas
réalisable ça bon voilà
oui mais c'est Richard c'est intervenir
oui simplement pour compléter le propos
du ministre en m'excusant d'avoir du
m'absenter un moment mais je pense
monsieur le ministre que ce serait très
important que vous nous adressiez dès
maintenant la proposition de
l'amendement que vous voulez faire
puisque si je comprends bien le comité
de suivi parlementaire n'est pas dans le
projet de loi à l'heure actuelle ça
serait un alinéa supplémentaire ou une
série d'alinéas supplémentaires en
complément de l'article d'habilitation
donc je pense que ce serait vraiment
judicieux que vous nous envoyez un
projet martyr et éventuellement le
complète un peu sur la façon notamment
dans son choisi les membres du comité
parlementaire
mais c'est la seule solution viable de
toute manière moi je n'y vois
personnellement aucun inconvénient mais
qu'on pense nos rapporteurs vous savez
moi je veux on a il y a longtemps que
j'exprime l'idée du suivi par le montant
je vais pas me renier je
ma parole manga évidemment devant vous
bon
si vous souhaitez qu'on l'inscrive dans
le texte j'ai déjà dit que je n'y étais
évidemment pas opposé ça peut rassurer
le débat a eu lieu très souvent
dans des cas de
réflexion sur une habilitation et
les gouvernements successifs non pas mis
en place ce type de concertation
et si j'avais l'esprit malin ce qui
m'arrive que
le 29 février des années bissextiles
je pense que le secrétariat général du
gouvernement il serait pour quelque
chose en disant bah si habilitation
ça reste dans l'exécutif il me semble
que sur un sujet
aussi
délicat que celui-là et s'il y a
justement une relation de confiance il
vaut mieux que ce soit dans la loi
alors que je prenais toujours le
contraire puisque les pouvoirs du
Parlement n'ont pas besoin d'être
rappelé dans une loi mais sur ce cas là
je crois qu'il faut vraiment le préciser
oui oui
bien sûr
et le fait qu'il soit de mauvaise foi le
29 février
je l'ai entendu je l'ai noté sur mes
tablettes
voilà les allées bissextiles nous
n'aurons pas des changes monsieur le
Sénat l'année prochaine donc je crois
que madame n'a pas forcément eu réponse
à ces questions monsieur le ministre
est-ce que Madame Carrère souhaite bien
avoir réponse à ces questions oui
c'était plus des
remarques que j'ai apporté que des
questions fondamentales mais
perçu comme des remarques davantage que
c'était les remontées un petit peu de la
mission que l'on est en train de faire
la parole mesdames les rapporteurs
tout va bien tout va bien mais bon et
bien je n'ai plus qu'à vous remercier
Monsieur le Ministre pour cette longue
audition merci de votre disponibilité
chers collègues nous nous retrouvons
demain à 9h30 dans notre salle
habituelle pour notre réunion du
mercredi merci bonne soirée à tous merci